[Music]
this is the last of us a gritty story of
human survival in a post-apocalyptic
America but the last of us is more than
a 20-hour escort mission the emotional
development of the characters take
center stage and makes for one of the
greatest video game narratives ever told
it's story time once again here on
PlayStation granade
here's the Last of Us in a nutshell
ready for you to play The Last of Us
part 2 our story begins with Sarah
waiting up for her father to return home
from work on his birthday with only 10
minutes of the day remaining she gives
him Joel a gift a new watch this watch
will still be here at the end of this
story a bond from father to daughter and
if you wondering how Sarah got the cash
for it drugs I sell hardcore drugs oh
good we start helping out with the
mortgage then yeah you wish later in the
night Sarah wakes and the world has
changed forever
something is infecting people Joel and
Sarah meet up with Tommy Joe's brother
and quickly attempt to flee the city but
they aren't the only ones with that plan
and this happens all three survived but
Sarah now has a broken leg and must be
carried by Joel while Tommy keeps them
both safe they somehow make it out of
the city but there is no happy ending
here a military guard stops them and on
command from the US government guns both
down
before the killers confirmed Tommy takes
out the soldier and saved Joel but Sarah
is mortally wounded passing away in
Joel's arms come on please Sarah before
we can truly process these actions Joel
awakes from his nightmare 20 years have
passed and he remains tormented by the
loss of his daughter but Joel keeps on
living 20 years after the first
sightings of these zombie-like creatures
the world has now changed the court
accepts virus infects the human brain
replacing humanity with a blind rage to
attack and potentially consume the non
infected the virus is so potent a single
scratch or bite will change anyone in a
mere few hours Joel now lives in Boston
in one of the numerous quarantine zones
on one side the military continuing to
rule rightly or wrongly with an iron
fist on the other side a band of rebels
formed named the fireflies to directly
combat the military with the Corps
desire to find a cure for this plague
Joel doesn't fit on either side and
finds his own niche as a smuggler along
with his business partner Tess a
strong-minded no-nonsense individual who
arrives with news that another smuggler
Robert is attempting to move in on their
weaponry business and has sent goons to
kill Tess the two quickly hunt down
Roberts and torture him for information
but it's too late he's already sold the
weapons to the fireflies you know the
rebels were the heart the real question
here will test let Robert lay off no no
so now the pair need to find the
fireflies where could they be none other
than the leader of the fireflies herself
Marlene appears it's like it's a video
game of something in return for the guns
Marlene asks Joel and Tess to smuggle
something she has she can't do it
herself because she's been shot and will
likely die very soon the pair agree and
then we find out what they will be
smuggling
oh wait let her go
yeah a teenage girl they're gonna take
her to the Capitol building but I don't
think Joel and Ellie like each other I
want y'all to watch over long story
short they agree on the way to the
Capitol building the group are captured
by soldiers using this device here they
can tell if anyone has the virus and if
they do they are shot on sight Tess and
Joel passed the test but out of nowhere
Ellie attacks the soldier and the trio
kill them all
Ellie reveals she was bitten three weeks
ago and has not changed at all she is
immune therefore she is the key to
vaccination with this bombshell out of
the way the trio make it to the drop
point but to last every single Firefly
waiting has been killed this story is
over and only gets worse as Tess has
news she is infected as the military
arrived Tess makes Joel promise to get
Ellie to the fireflies she is so
dedicated to this new cause at the test
days to fight the soldiers to give Joel
time to escape laying down her life in
the process yes this hits Joel hard but
a combination of focused anger and his
loyalty tests see him continue this
mission
whereas Ellie is quickly growing fond of
Joel and forming a bond what you say
goes
the only firefly Joel knows is his
brother Tommy
but he left that rebel faction and moved
away to Wyoming and at present Joel and
Ellie are in Boston they need a vehicle
and Joel knows someone who can help this
is Bill the most volatile friend you
could ever wish for his dislike of
everyone is shown to us firsthand when
his partner in life is found hanged
leaving a suicide note of hatred towards
bill he was my partner in the end bill
does the right thing and helps Joel and
Ellie and even teaches Joel a few new
tricks and tactics too now on the road
Joel and Ellie make their way to find
Tommy along the way they are tricked
and attacked by multiple groups proving
once again in the apocalypse human
beings remain the real threat to
humanity but to people they find are not
as evil as you think meet Henry and his
younger brother Sam the two are also
attempting to find the fireflies and
agree to work with Joel and Ellie one
scene in particular is important to note
early on when passing through the toy
store Sam what are you doing nothing get
rid of it my backpack is practically
empty
what's the world got take your stuff it
was enough to rule what is it we only
take what we have to right Henry is so
focused on survival that he doesn't
allow his brother to be a child and
enjoy things a child should his
single-minded viewpoint is very similar
to Joel check this out later the group
is attacked by a militarized truck with
heavy weaponry whilst escaping Henry
decides to abandon Joel we're leavin
what but in a touching moment of loyalty
Ellie jumps back into harm's way to stay
with her protector the two work together
to escape but now they're trapped above
a Rapid River and is now a good time to
remind you that Ellie cannot swim well
the choice do we have we jump no it's
too high and you can't swim
somehow Ellie and Joel are pulled from
the river by Henry the man who moments
before left them to die Joel at his most
enraged can't understand why and is
close to shooting Henry but Henry can
explain this in one sentence it was the
other way around which you would come
back for us
profound survival and priorities summed
up instantly over time Henry and Joel
finally bond and reach a mutual respect
for one another
whilst in the other room Ellie shows her
caring yet again revealing she picked up
that toy that Sam was looking at in the
store but some isn't as excited as you'd
expect and we soon find out why some is
infected the following morning Ellie
comes in to wake Sam Henry takes his
time but does come to terms with what
his brother has become and shoots him
but the grief of failing to protect him
took its toll on Henry and Henry turned
the gun on himself another chilling
reminder that life is fragile by the
autumn time Ellie and Jos relationship
is at its strongest and something
finally goes well for the duo as they
find Tommy who has helped to establish a
new town with his wife Maria things
aren't perfect here for them as bandits
and the infected regularly attack but
they do have hydroelectric power thanks
to a nearby dam meaning they have
electricity here or they will do soon if
they get things working as the brothers
get to know each other again
Tommy attempts to give Joel a photo of
Sarah but he turns it down he doesn't
want this reminder Joel then drops a
bombshell and asks Tommy to take Ellie
to the fireflies as he doesn't want to
be around her any longer
it looks like emotionally he doesn't
want to make that commitment to another
daughter when Tommy finally agrees to
this it's too late Ellie has run away
feeling betrayed by Joel
Joel and Tommy fight through many
bandits to locate Ellie and that desire
to rescue her finally sees Joel realized
he does see Ellie as his daughter not to
replace Sarah but as a second chance to
keep her safe and now the two decide to
stay together Tommy tells Joel how to
find the fireflies and if you need
details it's University eastern Colorado
and the to set off once again Oh
squirrel unsurprisingly when Joel and
Ellie arrive the fireflies have left
leaving another breadcrumb to follow
before they can leave a new group
attacks the pair but this time Joel
doesn't get through this unscathed Ellie
once again shows her desire to be with
her father figure and single handedly
escorts Joel to their horse and
miraculously
they escape she's a warrior and a
protector now in equal measure this
plight isn't over as the second the pair
feels safe
[Applause]
Joel is approaching death
you gotta get up
[Music]
winter is here and Ellie is all alone we
control her for the first time in the
game hunting rabbits and deer but
there's no sign of Joel Ellie bumps into
other hunters and makes a fragile
alliance to fight off another infect in
heart the deal was simple Ellie would
give up her share of the hunted deer in
return for medical supplies from David's
group both sides keep to the agreement
but David reveals a story his group were
attacked while searching for supplies at
Colorado University buy and get theirs
is crazy man traveling a little girl by
a crazy man and a little girl david
allows Ellie to leave with the medical
supplies just as we all hoped those
supplies were indeed for Joel a shot of
penicillin to help the healing process
and it also shows us that the Katis EPS
virus may be a deadly fungus but there's
also other funguses like this one which
created penicillin I don't know why that
stuck with me for so long but it did
anyway before I can turn this into a
science lesson David's group have
arrived they tracked Ellie in order to
find and kill Joel in a bid to save him
Ellie leads them away but David is ahead
at every step
here's where things become real early
awakens to see with her own eyes
David's camp are cannibals looking for
survivors for their next meal it's also
suggested here that David would prefer
to keep Elly alive for reasons which
scare the hell out of me but this girl
is far too strong minded to comply
breaking David's finger
David reluctantly makes the call to kill
Ellie but just before Ellie has a
last-ditch attempt to save herself
during this moment of hesitation Ellie
kills one of her captors and enters into
a deadly game of hide and seek in a
burning building thankfully our girl is
unstoppable and finally emotionally
takes out her tormentor
speaking of being unstoppable
Joel although not fully fit returns to
the land of the living and becomes a man
on a mission to find Ellie I mean it his
dedication to finding her is frightening
he arrives just in time to get Ellie out
of that burning wreckage time moves
forward once again to spring Joel and
Ellie still chasing the fireflies across
America during this segment a moment
unheard of in video games happens rarely
spots a giraffe for the first time in
her life a real giraffe walks by and
allows us to pet it I can't really
explain why this scene is so important I
think it's because there's a buildup of
their relationship to this point and
they both realize they are approaching
the end of their journey the Firefly
stronghold is meters away in a crushing
twist of fate whilst crossing a body of
water which we've done tens of times in
the game already
Joel's footing gives out and he's
trapped underwater
once again Ellie who can't swim jumps to
his rescue but this time neither I
prepared
joël survives but Ellie doesn't and
before he can save her life one more
time Joel is captured but look who's
there
Marlene had the figurehead of the
Firefly organization all healed up she
survived somehow Joel did his job and
got Ellie home she's alright
Ellie survived but this happy moment is
quickly followed by a crushing blow
Ellie is to undergo surgery
oh you mean surgery the doctors tell me
the cordyceps the growth inside her is
somehow mutated it's why she's immune
once they remove it they'll be able to
reverse-engineer a vaccine a cure a
vaccine we did it this is the endgame
but for this to happen
Ellie must die how would you react save
the human race or save Ellie it doesn't
take Joel long to make his choice a
second
Joel fights through countless fireflies
to reach Ellie before the surgeons take
her life although they aren't related by
blood no vaccine is worth the life of
Joel's daughter he needs her to survive
this in a repeat of the scene from the
beginning of the story
Joel races to safety with his daughter
in his arms but then you can't save her
even if you get her out of here then
what how long before she's torn to
pieces by pack of clickers Joel already
made his choice let me go
you just come after her when Ellie
finally awakens Joel is driving them
back to Tommy's and makes a key decision
here to lie to Ellie turns out there's a
whole lot more like you really people
that are immune as dozens actually
they've actually they've stopped looking
for a cure in the final scene the pair
end their journey and reached Tommy's
town back in Jackson but Ellie is uneasy
and doesn't trust everything joel has
set here's how the last of us ends back
in Boston back when I was bitten I
wasn't alone my best friend was there as
she got bit too we didn't know what to
do so she says let's just wait it out
you know we can be all poetic and just
lose our minds together I'm still
waiting for my turn
Ellie her name was Riley and she was the
first to die and then it was tests and
I'm Sam nothing that he's on you you
don't understand I struggled for a long
time with surviving no matter what you
keep finding something to fight for
now I know that's not what you want to
hear I swear to me
swear to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true
I swear
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]